[Music]
melanie is in omaha nebraska hi melanie
how are you
good afternoon how are you better than i
deserve what's up
um okay so i am the geek in my marriage
and
i also
work in the banking industry
and i am stuck i don't i can't make a
decision so i need you to help me
we can we can help we have an opinion i
promise
i don't even know what it is but we have
an opinion i'm sure
yeah okay so we were doing really really
well about four years ago and then just
this last spring hit us really hard and
kind of put it upside down
so i am trying to decide
whether or not to get a heloc and i'm
thinking about doing it for the purpose
of consolidating high interest rate debt
my pros are a lower interest rate to
knock out credit card debt with higher
interest rate and then beat the system
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
throw down principal payments before the
end of each billing cycle
to make the debt go down faster and then
less interest will go towards
what the heloc is
my cons are right now my current dti is
55 it needs to be below 45
to qualify in order for me to do that i
will have to tie in a car loan that
we
acquired this year but that car loan is
at a fixed
4.75 percent and with the way that the
interest rate keeps going up with wall
street i don't know if putting that car
loan over into a heloc is a smart
decision or a dumb decision
but i was able to call the credit card
company yesterday and negotiate that
24.99
down to
16.99 for a year only what would dave do
what's the balance on the car
the car is 45 000.
what's your household income
um so this is going to be a little
finicky um together my husband i make
105 000 a year but i have a side job
that's kind of under the table
and i can bring in an extra 40 thousand
dollars
okay and what is how much credit card
debt do you have
fifteen
okay what other debt do you have
other than your house um
so
we literally drove both of our cars
until the wheels fell off and it
happened exactly a month apart this
spring
we made a family trip to go down to
texas to see some family down there
and i kid you not a week before we went
the engine blew in our 2012 traverse
and i tried everything i could to fix it
i used all of our expenses and then i
ended up putting more money on the
credit card which is why it went up it
got to the point where the mechanic was
like just stop it's not gonna happen and
i'm like
fine so then we ended up getting that
new traverse not new but a huge traverse
and
um and then
our other car which was a
ten
2010
you have forty five thousand on one car
fifteen thousand credit card debt and
what other debt
um we have another car with fifteen
thousand
and then um our mortgage is 318. 318
000. okay no you don't need a home
equity loan you need to sell a 45 000
car that's insanity
yeah you're broke
and you're trying to fix this with
interest rates because you did a stupid
but over purchase because you were
dramified
correct yeah
so i'm looking at
75 000 worth of debt total correct
outside of the house so if we get rid of
the car
and we get you
something reasonable you know five
thousand dollar car
that leaves you with
about thirty thousand left what's the
car worth that's why you have 15 000
loan on it
i'm driving it and i'm going to take
this 140 000 and clean this mess up on
beans and rice rice and beans you got a
great income you don't have an interest
rate problem you have a lifestyle
problem
correct
cut your lifestyle to nothing
car payments for six years scorched
earth you don't need a car payment for
six years you need to be out of debt in
one year
no we didn't have car payments for six
years well until you lost your mind
and then you went through then you went
through the the crazy period of your
life
when you went crazy
and now you got yourself in sixty
thousand dollars in car debt
yeah a home equity loan doesn't fix that
getting rid of the cars fixes it or
getting rid of the debt fixes it and you
can't get rid of the debt soon enough to
suit me if you keep the 45 000 car so
i'm moving way down in car no vacations
no eating out scorched earth
no spending on anything and 140 000 will
pay off 30 000
inside of a year pretty easy actually
yeah are you guys doing any investing
right now
no
okay do you have any money in savings
um we did until
we threw it all at trying to save that
other car
okay so you don't have any money in
savings right now
no okay
well let's get you a thousand dollar
starter emergency fund and after that
we're selling this car today and beyond
that you got 140 grand income we're
gonna pay off 30 you're gonna drive
around a beater car
and uh we'll clean this mess up real
quick with that kind of income here's
the thing melanie you're trained as a
banker in finance at some level in order
to be in the job that you're in and the
thing that we're taught in academia is
that interest rate is everything and if
we can simply cut the interest rate we
can solve all these problems and so you
called and negotiated 24 down to 16
24.99 down to 1699 that was a good move
by the way excellent job uh but here's
the thing
interest rate mathematically is
irrelevant when you're going to pay it
all off in one year
correct
so the home equity loan doesn't solve
anything
what the home equity loan does it's very
dangerous
is it moves everything over onto your
home and you feel like you did something
and you drag this mess out for five
years instead of cleaning it up in 12
months
okay all right
this is exactly what i was thinking yeah
but we've been going back and forth home
equity loan is a form of it's a form of
denial
yes you're treating the symptom which is
the debt instead of the problem which is
what caused the debt
and you fix the problem with the
cutting the end or cutting the out go to
zero
cranking up the side hustle
and cranking down life for one year and
and you know undoing the big dumb
decision which was the 45 000 car
and it's painful people are going to
think you've lost your mind and what
you're going to wonder gosh man i'm
getting rid of this car my failure
you're not a failure you're just you
just made a mistake and you're fixing
the mistake
i've done a lot dumber things than what
you did but this was dumb
it's on it's on the dumb list
so um but but you're not dumb you just
did a dumb thing there's two different
things i've done i'm not done but i've
done a lot of dumb things and george
george don't get me started don't tell
me how many dumb things he's done so but
i haven't done the heloc that one hasn't
uh never tricked me oh i had i did he
heal that's dan that put your home at
risk back in my old real estate
investing days when i borrowed
everything in sight i he locked
everything
and then i unlocked it and locked it
again
this is the ramsey show